[Music]
imagine you're asked to invent something
new it could be whatever you want made
from anything you choose in any shape or
size that kind of creative freedom
sounds so liberating doesn't it or does
it if you're like most people you'd
probably be paralyzed by this task
without more guidance where would you
even begin as it turns out boundless
freedom isn't always helpful in reality
any project is restricted by many
factors such as the cost what materials
you have at your disposal and unbreak
the laws of physics these factors are
called creative constraints and they're
the requirements and limitations we have
to address in order to accomplish a goal
creative constraints apply across
professionals to architects as artists
writers engineers and scientists in many
fields constraints play a special role
as drivers of discovery and invention
during the scientific process in
particular constraints are an essential
part of experimental design for instance
a scientist studying onion virus would
consider how can I use the tools and
techniques at hand to create an
experiment that tells me how this virus
infects the body's cells and what are
the limits of my knowledge that prevent
me from understanding this new viral
pathway in engineering constraints have
us apply our scientific discoveries to
invent something new and useful
take for example the Landers Viking 1
and 2 which relied on thrusters to
arrive safely on the surface of Mars the
problem those thrusters left foreign
chemicals on the ground contaminating
soil fails so a new constraint was
introduced how can we land a probe on
Mars without introducing chemicals from
Earth the next Pathfinder mission used
an airbag system to allow the rover to
bounce and roll to a halt without
burning contaminating fuel years later
we wanted to send a much larger rover
Curiosity however it was too large for
the airbag design so another constraint
was defined how can land a large Rover
while still keeping rockets away from
the Martian soil in response engineers
had a wild idea they design a sky crane
similar to the claw machine at toy
stores it would lower the rover from
high above the surface
with each intention the engineers
demonstrated an essential habit of
scientific thinking that solutions must
recognize the limitations of current
technology in order to advance it
sometimes this progress is iterative as
in how can I make a better parachute to
land my rover and sometimes it's
innovative like how to reach our goal
when the best possible parachute isn't
going to work in both cases the
constraints guide decision-making to
ensure we reach each objective
here's another Mars problem get to
dissolve say we want to send astronauts
will need water they rely on a
filtration system that keeps the water
very moist and enables 100% recovery
those are some pretty tough constraints
and we may not have the technology for
it now but in the process of trying to
meet these objective we might discover
other applications of any inventions
that result or building an innovative
water filtration system could provide a
solution for farmers milking in drought
stricken regions or awake to a municipal
water in polluted cities in fact many
scientific advances have occurred when
serendipitous failures in one field
address the constraints of another when
scientists Alexander Fleming mistakenly
contaminated a petri dish in the lab it
led to the discovery of the first
antibiotic penicillin the same is true
of synthetic dye plastic and gunpowder
all were created mistaken but went on to
address the constraints of other
understanding constraints the guides of
scientific progress and what's true in
science is also true in many other
fields constraints aren't the boundaries
of creativity but the foundation of it
[Music]
you